in 2009 serial entrepreneur Craig Zucker
had a hit product on his hands
buckyballs
desk toys comprised of supercharged mini
magnets that were flying off the shelves
and into the shopping carts of fidgety
handed customers large number of
children have had invasive surgery to
remove these Falls once they're in their
intestine suckas troubles began last
year when the federal Consumer Product
Safety Commission sought to ban and
recall the product on the grounds that
it was dangerous for children see these
magnets they can make holes in your
stomach seriously it's true that if
swallowed these powerful tiny balls can
cause internal bleeding because they
seek to find other magnets when lodged
in a person's bowels or intestinal tract
but banning the product was
statistically ridiculous as a report in
The Huffington Post explained there were
22 reported incidents of ingested
buckyballs from 2009 to October 2011 or
1 for every 100,000 sets sold meaning
the product is orders of magnitude less
risky than dogs tennis skateboarding and
poisonous household chemicals and the
product was clearly marked keep away
from all children finding himself in the
crosshairs of federal regulators Craig
Zuka did the opposite of pull back he
went on a publicity rampage to save
buckyballs there are many products that
have a far greater rate of incident
created the best safety program in both
the magnet industry and most industries
in fact they simply want to put us out
of business why not also bad Hippos hot
dogs beds and stairs
he asked suckers company even created a
poster encouraging supporters to give
CPSC chairwoman Ines 10 about a ring on
her psychic hotline sucker eventually
conceded defeat buckyballs disappeared
from stores and maxfield and Overson
suckers company was dissolved but that's
not the end of the story the Consumer
Product Safety Commission recently sued
Craig Zucker holding him personally
liable for the cost of recalling
buckyballs which the agency claims will
come to about 57 million dollars the
case is getting widespread attention in
legal circles because it's the first
time the Commission has attempted to
hold a former officer personally
responsible for the actions of a defunct
corporation is
consumer product safety commission
carrying out a personal vendetta against
Craig Zucker i sat down with him to
discuss the lawsuit and a new initiative
to help raise money to cover his legal
fees so when the Consumer Product Safety
Commission issued a total recall of your
product buckyballs
you didn't exactly act like my CEOs
would act in that position you went
straight to the public sphere why was
that we had to do it because the
Consumer Product Safety Commission went
straight to the public sphere I mean you
know they sued the company on July 25th
2012 and we found out by reading about
it in the USA Today so you know at the
same time that they went to the media
they also started going to our retail
partners and and having product pulled
from shelves and we were just kind of
boxed in and and really what we needed
was public support and we wanted you
know people in Washington and our
customers and consumers in general to be
aware of what was happening did you ever
try to plead your case behind closed
doors or was that never an option for
you there was not a lot of negotiating
that was happening there was that they
they went straight to court and we kind
of went straight to the court of public
opinion do you have any inkling as to
why the Commission went straight off to
you well first of all it is an
unprecedented action and and I I don't I
can't answer it I don't know but I think
a lot of people a lot of people in
Washington a lot of people in the
business and legal community look at the
aggressive campaign that Maxiell no
Burton ran in 2012 which was to save our
balls campaign and and it was kind of me
as the CEO being the face of that and I
think a lot of people interpret what's
happening now as retaliation for us
speaking out against the CPSC and
disagreeing with their actions and if
not you then who is liable for the cost
of the recall well the commissioners
estimated the 57 million dollar cost
which is crazy because it's more than
that company ever did in sales so I
don't know how they came up with the
number but you know this happens all the
time companies go out of business and
products end up the Commissioner wants
the products recalled and what's
happened in every other instance is a
press release goes up and it warns
consumers of the the defect or the
alleged defect and it urges them to get
rid of the product I think the
Commission is using this as a test-case
and it's a dangerous test case because
warnings are the regulatory scheme for
thousands and thousands of products it's
it's why we're allowed to have you know
household cleaners under our sink it's
it's why we're allowed to have power
tools because the manufacturers and the
government assume that consumers will
adhere to the warnings if you start to
go down the path of saying warnings
don't work anymore I think what you're
gonna start to see is thousands of
products all sorts of products either
for adults or children banned and
recalled based on this really silly idea
that warnings work on some products but
but not others and what what will happen
if you lose this case will you file for
personal bankruptcy I'm not going to
lose the case so I'm not concerned about
that but I certainly don't have fifty
seven million dollars the company didn't
even do close to that in the sales and
this was a company with multiple owners
and and expenses and we've lost a lot of
money in 2012 before having to go out of
business you know lawyers aren't cheap
as you can imagine so I don't intend to
lose and I haven't thought about what I
will do if we do and so you've launched
this recent campaign you have the save
our balls and you've got United we ball
yeah can you tell us a little bit about
that we've developed a series of
products one is called Liberty balls and
one's called ball of rights they're
their larger magnetic balls for your
desk and 100 percent of the profits of
the company go towards the legal fees of
defending the Consumer Product Safety
Commission's lawsuit against me and
against maxfield new Burton is there a
danger the Commission also pulling these
products yeah you never know but they
are large enough where they they don't
fit down the small parts cylinder are
you partially doing this at behalf of
other companies who might be in the
future put in a similar position yeah
absolutely I mean we're we're very
concerned about a precedent being set
and the precedent that would be set here
is that limited liability for
entrepreneurs for company officers for
managers would disappear and and so you
know the the comparison that we've made
is you know you a guy owns a hardware
store and he sells somebody a power tool
with with proper warning
and labels and you know unfortunately a
child accesses that in his injured in
the future if this precedent were to be
set that individual is personally and
financially responsible for what happens
and that's just not the way that the
American legal and business system is
set up we've developed corporations and
corporate structures and LLC's to limit
the liability of individuals it's what
allows us as Americans and business
owners to innovate to create new
businesses to take chances to take risks
and I think without it there's a very
very chilling and dangerous precedent
that would be set great are they the
Liberty Bowl says this may I have a look
at your balls absolutely I always wanted
to say that well thank you very much for
joining us for sure thanks